Speaker 1: Let's go to Dan from Illinois. Dan
from Illinois. Welcome to the David Pakman show.
What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hi, David.
Speaker 1: Can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Oh, I'm so glad you picked me. Before
I get to my question. I wanted to congratulate
you on having such an excellent show. And I have
been a viewer for a couple of years now. And I
think the reason why I've become a daily viewer
of yours is because the quality of what you
do and the degree to which you think through
and present things is so above and beyond what is
out there. Wow. Well, I appreciate that. Yes. And
specifically, if I could. If I could. If I could
say. I think the thing that's most valuable to me
is when you do very specific breakdowns that that
delve into issues very deeply. A lot of what's out
there in the media, especially corporate media, it
doesn't it doesn't really help people understand
complex issues. And I love what you do.
Speaker 1: So. Well, I appreciate
that very much. Dan, thank you.
Speaker 2: I absolutely encourage
you to continue on that. And so that
being said, the question that I have is
about something that you and I agree on, okay?
That you that you've talked about, But I haven't
heard you go more in depth in. So you've talked
about the importance of media literacy. Yes. And I
would love to hear your thoughts on, I guess, both
ways. Like if you could wave a magic wand, how
would you approach media literacy, but also maybe
like what would fit into reality? Because I mean,
I could speak them where I'll let you answer.
Speaker 1: Well, as I've said before,
I think that really you really want to
be teaching media literacy as young as
people start consuming media. Now, how do you
teach a two year old who watches cartoons,
media literacy? Well, you know, you start to
distinguish commercials from the programing,
I think. Right. I mean, you start very
simple. But as a matter of school curriculum,
certainly by sixth grade, there should be just
it should be standard that we're teaching media
literacy, understanding the difference between
news and opinion. Understanding the impact of,
you know, advertisers, product placement.
Just because you saw something on TV or on
the Internet, does it mean it's true? What's the
difference for you? All of this basic stuff. The
earlier you arm people with the tools needed,
the less that they're ever going to fall for
Fox News or Newsmax. And it's sort of like it's
sort of like a vaccine against disinformation.
So I would like to see it just be a standard
part of school curriculum starting probably I
used to say seventh grade. Now I'm probably
more like sixth grade, maybe even fifth.
Speaker 2: I couldn't agree more. I think that
this is actually a core of what is causing many,
many issues because it's so easy
for anyone to say anything. Yes.
And just understanding sort of the psychology
of media, how it affects people. There's a lot
of people using and, you know, nefarious ways,
self-serving ways. And from from my vantage point,
it's sort of feeling like I'm watching things
were sort of sliding off of the cliff with 100%
without that sense of how are we going to come
back from this? Do you have any voices or books
or resources that you've looked to in terms of
people who are kind of have expertise in that,
that has informed your sense of
like how that could actually be
done or how we could actually look to do that?
Speaker 1: Not from a policy standpoint. You know,
on my book recommendation list, on my
website, I have tons of books about
thinking that I recommend, but none of them are
policy oriented in that way. But I'll look around
and see if there are any.
Speaker 2: Awesome. Well,
thank you so much. That answers what I
wanted to talk to you about. All right.
Speaker 1: Dan from Illinois, very much appreciate
the call. We're going to take more calls,
but let's take a very quick break and then we'll
be back. If you're holding on to talk to me,
don't hang up because we're
going right back to the phones